Can you please explain what some of this means? Okay, this person said in information
on their RGCC test. So, as everybody know what the RGCC test is. So, the RGCC test,
they have multiple different things that you could run with RGCC. It's also known as
the Greek test. That tests different genetic specific genetic markers that would be specific
to different tumors. And it can be build as a as a cancer test that can predict cancer
in a person. So, I don't I think I have cancer, but I don't know. So, I can run the RGCC test
and run this particular test with RGCC, which this person ran. And they might get some
inkling whether they have cancer or not. Now, I certainly hope that the doctor that ordered
I don't order the RGCC test. We don't do the RGCC test. I hope the doctor that ordered
this test didn't tell you or if you have ever done it, that you've never had a doctor
tell you that we'll do this RGCC test. And this will tell you if you have cancer or not.
Because the only thing that can tell you if you have cancer or not from a medical legal
standpoint is a biopsy. Nothing else can tell you from a medical legal standpoint. It could
give you clues, but it can't tell you specifically. You have paid greater cancer. You have liver
cancer. You have this cancer. Now, certainly scans, like a CT scan, especially on a PET scan,
even more so, and an MRI can a radiologist who's a good radiologist who's looked at 50,000 slides
can look at it and go to that's cancer. But then they even write in the port that says,
this is suggestive at astrocytoma, or this is suggestive colorectal adenocarcinoma,
but they can't legally say that it is because the only way that you can say that it is cancer
is through a biopsy. No, a radiologist has looked at these scans a million times and they could
they know that they had no carcinoma, but they can't legally say that that's why you see that type of
verbiage called a CT scan, but they say it's suggestive of. It's, you know, that type of protective
terminology so that they're suggesting that this is a progression of the cancer, or this is the
test, this is to the bone, but without a biopsy, I can't be for sure. So with the RGCC test, it's the
same thing. They can say this is suggestive of this type of cancer, but they can't say that it's
cancer, nor they can they be specific that it is the exact cancer that you're looking for.
This, uh, the rest of this question I think was a comment from the doctor who ran the test that said
this test was supposed to tell me, or this, this artist with the patient, this test was supposed
to tell me the exact tissue the cancer is coming from. So if you, if you thought that and you were
told by the ordinary doctor, that was incorrect. Maybe they didn't say that and maybe that's what you
heard. Maybe they did say that and that was misinformation. Um, can you help me understand this?
For example, what is TN, TTN morbid, um, and what does it likely path, what does likely pathogenic
mean? Um, I can, I don't interpret that RGCC test. So if you guys go through the RGCC test through
another practitioner, you need to have that other practitioner interpret it for you because that's not
my specialty. I don't run that test. I haven't done intensive study on that test and I don't plan to
because that's my specialty. So you have to have them interpret that TTN morbid. I don't know what
that means. That's a terminology specifically from RGCC, but likely pathogenic this term right here.
So they say this is likely pathogenic. That is another one of those terms that like a radiologist would
say, this is suggestive of, you know, likely pathogenic means this is probably cancer, but I can't say
that because legally you would have to do a biopsy to say that. So unfortunately, I have had multiple
people come to me and say I did the RGCC test because the practitioner said that's what's going to
diagnose the cancer. And I have said, okay, you got to understand that does not diagnose cancer.
You know, legally, the only diagnosis of cancer that you could get is through a biopsy. So
I hope practitioners that run these tests aren't giving misinformation because they're not an
expensive test to run. And if they're leaving people with the same doubt that they had before they had
the test, that I question the value. This is the same thing I say, you know, with every test that you
do, you have to weigh it out between, okay, is this going to give me information that's going to
help me change the way I treat my body? And if the answer is no, because I'm going to keep treating
the same way, then why do the test? If the answer is yeah, then then do the test. What makes me a
little sad is that if a practitioner told you that it wasn't going to give you information,
that it felt short of that, I feel bad for the person who read that test. So I apologize and I
can't give you any more information on that, that if you do call the office and say I want Dr.
Cutters to go over my RGCC test, Marie or whoever answers is going to say no, he doesn't do that.
Because I don't do that. I don't want to do something that I don't feel qualified to give you that
information that it's not going to help you. I want to stay within my lead in my knowledge center
which is pretty limited. I don't but that's not something I specialize in. I don't want to, I don't want
to let him box up and repeat so later.